it is great to be joined today by David
Faris who's an associate professor of
political science at Roosevelt
University also the author of it's time
to fight dirty how Democrats can build a
lasting majority in American politics
David it's so great to have you on and
this idea of fighting dirty is of
particular interest right now because my
audience has been very split recently in
reaction to some of the tactics that
have been adopted by anti-trump
activists I guess we would call them
this includes ruining the meals at
Mexican restaurants of different Trump
administration officials and showing up
outside of Christian Nielsen's condo and
playing audio of children crying at the
border and there's people in the
audience who say to me David we need to
take the high road because ultimately we
are going to be sort of our own judges
in the long run and we need to feel good
about the tactics that we're using we
don't want to stoop to their level and
the counter to that has been listen
you're dealing with people who are
ignoring all rules of decorum tone and
they are not going to be defeated unless
we do adopt some of these tactics so
let's start like at the broadest
possible level when we talk about
fighting dirty when you talk about it
what types of tactics are you referring
to sure I mean that's a great question
and thank for having me on the show
today I think when we talk about
fighting dirty we're not talking about
like cheating or lying we're talking
about sort of pressing the boundaries of
procedural norms and sort of pressing
the boundaries of legality and
constitutionality just as our opponents
have been doing I think over the last
twenty years so it means things like
using the full constitutional power of
the minority in Congress to hold up
legislation it means not cooperating
with with the president at all that is
not giving Democratic votes to
Republican priorities because sort of
bipartisanship makes the party in power
look good and we don't want that so I
think that in terms of this whole debate
about you know civility and you know
whether it's okay to confront people in
restaurants I would tend more towards
the the confrontational side of that
debate I think you know the best way to
enjoy a peaceful meal in DC is to not
put children in cages so
I think that our activists are well
within their rights to do things that
are very confrontational I mean I think
at the same time you don't want to do
things that are deeply alienating to
people whose votes you need so I think
the two Spurs will always be a
conversation about whether a certain
tactic is really gonna work or whether
it's not but if we believe our own
rhetoric that we're in the midst of a
crisis in the midst of an emergency I do
think that that means that we can do
certain things and and pursue certain
tactics that we might not under other
circumstances so let's pick a couple of
the things you mentioned and talk sort
of through the pragmatics of it because
I agree in principle with for example
start holding up all the legislation you
can hold up a Supreme Court nomination
if you can so on and so forth very
quickly though you get to for example
because of the way that that our House
and Senate work where Democrats are put
in a position where unless they because
something that they want is bundled in
to a bigger Republican bill or proposal
unless they go along with the Republican
bill or proposal that includes an
amendment that contains something that
the Democrats want they're simply not
getting it I hate that that's the way it
is I don't believe there's any rule that
says that that things have to be bundled
together in this way it is a deliberate
political tactic that is done but it
happened so what exactly do Democrats do
in that case well I mean I think first
of all I think that it's been very rare
for Republicans to actually be smart
about this because what they have done
is they've made the underlying
legislation that they're pushing so
repugnant that the things that they're
offering as these poison pills just
aren't enough to get Democrats to vote
for things I think the one the one time
that they really succeeded in doing this
well was with the Children's Health
Insurance Program during the standoff
over over daca and in January in
February that worked really well but
since then we have seen Republicans in
Congress sort of allowing the president
to dictate this extremely regressive
unpopular agenda to them and so even
when you know even if they put goodies
into a bill that diminishes legal
immigrations the United States it's not
going to get Democratic votes because
they just can't afford to attach
themselves so it's a legislation that
I think occasionally something will come
up that is a moral imperative for
Democrats and I think that we have seen
them willing to do this and I think that
they should do this and I'm thinking of
something like funding the wall this
mythical wall in exchange for for the
dreamers that's a that's a you know
that's a compromise Democrats offered
Republicans Republicans rejected it so I
think I'm only willing to compromise
when I think there's something really
morally imperative at stake and that
could be the dreamers that could be
something about family separations that
could be something about the ACA for 99
percent of everything else that's gonna
come before Congress I'm in favor of
obstruction I have made it pretty clear
that I'm to the left of the Democratic
Party and I think that the Democratic
Party is is but by and large to the
right of the American people in general
but that being said it is sort of the
de-facto path for progressivism right
now because of the sort of structural
impediments that exist to real third
party success and that that's not really
what we're going to talk about today but
it sort of sets up my question to you
which is is part of the problem that
Democrats just aren't to the left enough
on a lot of issues such that the
daylight between the Democrats and the
Republicans isn't big enough to really
take advantage from an activism point of
view on so many of the structural issues
campaign finance and many others that we
could talk about and I'm not someone to
be clear David that says there's no
different difference between Democrats
and Republicans I think the differences
are significant and they are numerous
but on some structural issues there
isn't that much difference and I wonder
if that holds back the ability to sort
of do the type of activism that you
suggest sure I think that this is
changing a lot I think it's changed a
lot over the last two years I still see
sort of pieces of that older Democratic
Party that was not as distinguishable
from Republicans as we might like and
I'm thinking about something like when
seventeen Democratic senators voted to
roll back the dodd-frank bill earlier
this year that was a sort of depressing
reprise of the kind of democratic
politics that I think many of us have
become frustrated with over the years
in terms of some other issues that I do
think that there's more difference
between Democrats than there was ten
years ago and if you think back to 2007
in the fight over immigration reform
there were still Democrats in the party
who voted against comprehensive
immigration reform know we can have some
problems with that legislation anyway
but the point is that ten years ago
there were a significant number of
Democrats in Congress who were unwilling
to sign on to a path to citizenship for
undocumented immigrants or or help for
the dreamers so I think that's really
changed over the last ten years to the
point where I think support to the
dreamers is like a litmus test for being
in the Democratic Party in the same way
that I think support for some form of
Medicare for All or single-payer health
insurance has become the default sort of
center of gravity in the party and
that's really really different than it
was ten years ago I think that there are
still some issues where there's a lot of
work to be done and I think that that is
in the party's relationship to big
business to corporations to drug
companies and you know that's that's
something that's gonna take a little bit
longer to shake out but I do think I'm
I'm heartened that I think that because
I think that energy which is on the side
of these progressive activists who are
doing the really hard work of running
for elections of holding people
accountable and I think in the long run
they might not win every primary but I
do think that we did that side of the
party is winning a lot of policy fact
that it was losing ten or twenty years
ago in part two of the interview we'll
talk about some of the specific areas
you think that that are good areas of
focus for activists and for Democrats
but to kind of set up that part of the
conversation we've talked about the way
in which gerrymandering in addition to
just the sort of urban-rural divide is a
structural disadvantage for Democrats
and we spoke to Bill o Goolsbee
professor bill Oglesby about that and
sort of the dynamics of that can you
talk about other than that what ways are
sort of illustrative of how Democrats
are at a structural disadvantage sure I
think the most important structural
disadvantage for Democrats is the US
Senate the Senate you know every state
has the same two senators you know
according to the Constitution whether
you have 700,000 people like my oming or
the
thirty-eight million people like
California over time the way our
politics have shaken out this is given
an enormous advantage to small rural
states like North Dakota
you know like Vermont Delaware but
they're mostly Republican right and
because this is uh namenda bull
like the Constitution says in order to
change the equal representation of the
Senate you have to have the state's
consent you're not gonna get that so
this is a structural feature of our
politics it's unchangeable and Democrats
have probably you know a significant
long-term deficit in the Senate because
there's 30 or 31 Republican leaning
states and 20 or 21 Democratic many
states so that you know in a vacuum
Republicans will hold the Senate more
often than that don't just by virtue of
the sort of the population dynamics of
this country and the way that states
were created and and the sort of the
unique problem that we have in this
country I've looked we have all of these
like really tiny states with very small
populations so that that is built into
our politics in ways that I think
Democrats have been really slow to
recognize and to address how would you
address something like that well we need
more states so because we can't do away
with the Senate we can't abolish the
Senate and we can't we can't change the
equal representation in the Senate what
we really need is to create more states
that lean democratic and there's easier
and harder ways to do this the sort of
the low-hanging fruit has statehood for
Washington DC in Puerto Rico both of
whom are significant entities that have
no representation in Congress right now
DC has had a referendum that over one
when we want to join the Union Porto
Rico is a little bit more complicated
story but I do think that another
referendum would would show that the
majority of Puerto Ricans would like to
join the United States is that as a 50
second or 51st state you know what order
you want to do it in both of those
states would send two Democratic
senators to DC and it would help sort of
alleviate the imbalance that we see
structurally in the Senate and as we
know in recent American history
if these would control all three
branches of government you basically get
nothing done that's where our
partisanship is so we need to think
about these creative solutions we could
also talk about the US Virgin Islands or
Guam or any number of territories the
u.s. holds that could vote
statehood in could join the Union as a
very small state now to the extent that
that Republicans hold the House and
Senate can they not simply prevent these
territories from obtaining statehood
even if by referendum they say we want
to do it oh yeah I mean right now this
is you know Republicans like Republicans
recognize that DC would be a massive
partisan loss for them and they probably
recognize the Puerto Rico would be too
and so they're others they not going to
act on this I think that so part of part
of the idea here is that they sort of an
elaborate fantasy where Democrats take
power over the next two cycles and we
wake up in January 2021 in charge of the
entire federal government and the
question is like what do we do at it
because we need to address the
structural barriers to progressive power
just as just as importantly as we as we
focus on you know policy differences or
you know medicare for all all these
things those are important the policy
fights are important and the policies
are important but it's also important if
we're gonna win in 2022 or 2024 to take
down some of these structural barriers
and we have to do so creatively like
within the constitutional framework
there's nothing stopping us from adding
States in part two of the interview
we're actually going to talk about some
of the other ideas that you have along
those lines we have been speaking with
David Farris who's an associate
professor of political science at
Roosevelt University the book is called
it's time to fight dirty how Democrats
can build a lasting majority in American
politics and we'll pick up the
conversation right there on tomorrow's
program we're continuing our
conversation with David Farris who's an
associate professor of political science
at Roosevelt University we've been
discussing the book it's time to fight
dirty how Democrats can build a lasting
majority in American politics so David
we spoke about some of the structural
disadvantages that affect Democrats in
the United States we talked about the
idea of adding states Washington DC was
mentioned as well as Puerto Rico and we
talked about some others what else is on
your list of tactics and approaches that
Democrats can employ that would be under
this general umbrella that you talked
about in the book of fighting dirty
sure I think the probably the most
important thing that that I write about
in the book is voting rights
but we've seen over the last 20 years in
the Republican Party is it concerted - a
unified effort to pass laws that are
legal you know that are constitutional
been upheld by the Supreme Court but
that are explicitly designed to drive
down Democratic turnout and to suppress
Democratic votes you know we're talking
about things like these cooker Cudi
cookie cutter voter ID laws that have
been passed in state after state
starting with the Bush administration
talking about things like felony
disenfranchisement laws you know the
restrictions and that many states have
placed on early voting or eliminating
days to vote early all of these are
tactics that Republicans are using
they're all legal or at least they've
been declared legal by the Supreme Court
I disagree but they're using them
because they know that it drives down
Democratic turnout and so in this case
fighting dirty it just means sort of
restoring the rights of these people who
have had their their franchise taken
away from them in the way that you can
do that we're fighting this battle on a
state-by-state level right now and we're
fighting for things like automatic voter
registration or we're challenging voter
ID laws that were we're fighting things
like the voter purges in Ohio is what
but what I read about is how all of
these problems are amenable to a
national piece of legislation passed by
a Democratic Congress and signed by a
Democratic president in that piece of
legislation because of the
Constitution's elections Clause could
eliminate voter ID laws that can
reinforce as a former or even current
felons they could declare at a national
voting holiday for federal elections and
it could demand that all states have
automatic voter registration and because
federal and state elections in most
times in places are run at the same time
the states would be forced to comply
probably for all of their elections the
end result of all of this would be
adding millions upon millions of
democratic-leaning voters to the voter
rolls be making them making it easier
for them to vote you would boost voter
turnout on Election Day and as we've
seen again and again when when our
people turnout we win and when they
don't we lose and that's why Republicans
are fighting so hard to prevent people
from voting because they fear the
electorate they fear the electorate
because their policies are radioactive
and the only way that they can stay in
power is to artificially drive down
turnout and so you know you can call it
fighting dirty talk whatever you want
but it's really imperative that
Democrats address this crisis in the
voting system in this country my
audience audience has been increasingly
asking me about vote packing a court
packing rather packing the court and
looking at an increase to the number of
Supreme Court justices of course when
the appointed additional justices would
be left-leaning rather rather than
right-leaning can you talk a little bit
about the dynamics of that and how
difficult it is to actually implement
sure I mean I think the reason that
we're talking about we're packing a
little bit right now is because of what
Republicans did in 2016 right which was
that they held a seat open the you know
President Obama had nominated Merrick
garland to fill that seat and they just
refused to do it and what they did was
they took advantage of another so
problem with our Constitution as the
Constitution does not always spell out
the obligations of the different
political actors so it says advice and
consent of the Senate but it doesn't say
whether the Senate like has to do it you
know how do they do it
hearings you know none of this none of
the ways that we used to confirm
nominees to the court who really spelled
out on the Constitution at all so
Republicans were right when they said we
don't have to do this right and it's
like okay well there's a lot of other
stuff that's not in the Constitution
either and most important thing that's
not in there is the number of justices
on the Supreme Court and so I think
probably many of your viewers are
familiar with the sort of the failure of
FDR's court packing plan in the 30s so
we you know he had a hostile Supreme
Court that was striking down important
measures of the New Deal and when he was
reelected in 1936 in - and you know we
inaugurated in 1937 he feared that the
best Supreme Court was going to strike
down the social security act just like a
signature piece of the New Deal right
and so he came up with this plan that
would have added a Justice of the
Supreme Court for everyone who was over
70 and wouldn't retire so it was like an
age-based
and that plan was defeated not because
it was unconstitutional but because his
allies in Congress just couldn't go
along with it and there's some evidence
to suggest he could have gotten
something through if he'd been willing
to compromise on adding fewer justices
is that what about at six and I think
the way that history remembers this
incident is that you know FDR had this
terrible idea it was defeated and hurt
him it cost him support over the rest of
his second term
but the underlying reality is that you
know the the willingness of both of our
parties to abide by these norms about
the Supreme Court appointments is
dependent on on both parties observing
them at all times and so when
Republicans broke that bargain in 2016
they sort of they opened up a Pandora's
box of responses and so I think the
Democrats will be well within their
rights to add two justices to the
Supreme Court and the next time they're
in power I do think that they should
offer a truce to Republicans in the form
of a constitutional amendment and this
is what I actually think they should be
talking about right now is the way that
the process is unfair you know some
presidents get zero appointments in four
years Pat Carter got zero now Donald
Trump gets two in two years which is
it's just preposterous right and if we
have an amendment that capped tenure on
the court at 18 years gave every
president the right to appoint two
justices for every four-year term we
could could we could like take this
ugliness right out of our politics I
think Republicans will say no to that
and I've been I think that Democrats
have every right to pack the courts in
response let's talk a little bit about
the electoral college there has been
particularly after Donald Trump lost in
the popular vote to Hillary Clinton by
almost three million votes in 2016 a
renewed sort of call for eliminating the
electoral college in favor of like a
national popular vote and I'm curious
where where you kind of come down on it
from is it actually good strategy for
the left because on the one hand it
appears as though it has screwed
Democrats twice in the last five
elections but at the same time what
Trump said is true in the sense that if
you know going in that it's a popular
vote election and not an electoral
college election you do campaign
differently and I wonder if it's
actually that clear that it would be
good for Democrats to get rid of the
electoral college sure I mean it's a
good question I mean I think one thing
to keep in mind is that we almost did
have this situation in the opposite
direction in 2004 so if John Kerry had
won another hundred thousand votes in
Ohio he would have won the electoral
college that lost the popular vote right
so I think the I you know I
the idea that this automatically like
that struck that the electoral college
is structurally biased against Democrats
I don't think it is in the same way that
you know the gerrymander house is or
that the US Senate is I think the
problems with the electoral college are
more about democratic legitimacy so you
know I think it's just very destructive
to the sort of shared sense the powers
being exercised over us legitimately for
the popular vote loser to take office
through this sort of antiquated
mechanism of the electoral college you
know unfortunately we're I think we're
stuck with it because it would require
probably a constitutional amendment to
get rid of I know that there's talk of
this super national popular vote compact
the interstate compact where a bunch of
states would get together and say that
they would give their electoral votes to
the popular vote winner no matter who
won the electoral college I don't think
anybody knows what the fate of that that
compact would be in the courts after
that election because it would be
contested obviously by whoever is losing
out my curiosity about that is would it
would it have to be contested
state-by-state I mean in the sense that
they're some of the legal opinions I've
read seem pretty adamant that states are
not States can decide for themselves in
other words how they handle the awarding
of their state's electoral vote so do
you know more about exactly what the
challenge would be I mean I know I think
that the interstate compact people I
think they're on pretty firm
constitutional grounds right yeah I
think that what would happen is that in
a handful of state let let's say that
this happens you know in a Republican
wins the electoral college two loses the
popular vote at this this compact is
enforced and then we you know we have
our little constitutional crisis I think
that people you know Republicans in a
small handful of states would sue or you
know they'd sue in the number of states
that they need to get back to 270 in the
electoral college and I think that that
would you know it would be expedited up
to the Supreme Court I'm sure because of
this for the timely nature just look
just the way the Bush v Gore was right
and
I think that there have been some cases
in the past where the Supreme Court has
narrowed the right of states to dispense
with electoral votes as they see fit and
I think that you know while a strict
reading of the Constitution would
suggest that the compact is on on firm
ground I think it's less firm in terms
of the precedent here because I think
American democracy does have an interest
in generally take the Electoral College
out of this but I think that American
democracy in general has an interest in
not having electors in the electoral
college just do whatever they want you
know and we've had a few you know
faithless electors here and there in our
elections where you know in a in an
election where the electoral college was
decided by 30 or 40 or 50 you know one
person is like I'm not voting for you
know I'm fighting for George Bush or
whatever that has happened and we don't
bother with it because it wasn't the
deciding vote but I do wonder what the
Supreme Court would do here because
we've times in our history where the
Supreme Court you know makes the wrong
decision or you know invents the
precedent or indents a rationale out of
the Constitution to justify making the
ruling that it wants to make and if this
were to happen with the current a 5-4
Republican majority on the court you
know my fear is that we'd have the
constitutional crisis we'd have we'd
have the litigation and ultimately the
Supreme Court would say like no the
states can't do those and the reality is
you know like they don't they don't
really need to be on firm constitutional
footing to do that they can just do it
so I don't know wouldn't hazard a
prediction about how this would shake
out and I think it would be productive
in the sense that you know we could
really bring this issue to a boil the
next time this happens and I think it's
important to do so but I'm not super
confident that the popular vote folks
would win in the very limited time we
have left I wanted to get your brief
thoughts as to whether any of the
changes that you and I have been talking
about our Pelosi and Schumer as the
leaders of the Democratic Party the
conduits through which this type of
change could be achieved you know in a
realistic sense yeah you know I'm
skeptical about that
yeah
I don't dislike Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer very accomplished people they're
working very hard I also think that they
they are sort of yearning for the return
of a norm based political order that's
just it's not coming back from the dead
and sort of they say things all the time
that make me think that they still don't
quite get the partisan environment that
they're operating in and so I would
prefer to see them both replaced by 2021
with sort of younger more activist
oriented leaders who are willing to sort
of make these really difficult decisions
to fight and to fight hard and if
necessary to fight dirty as long as it's
legal to because the Republican Party is
such a threat I think to the future of
this country right now that we need
political leaders that that recognize
that when I see them they they both just
look like they're having a little bit
too much fun right now like I don't I
don't it doesn't the sense of crisis
does not emanate from Chuck Schumer and
I really think we're in a crisis and I'd
like our leadership theorists like that
the book is called it's time to fight
dirty how Democrats can build a lasting
majority in American politics we've been
speaking with the book's author David
Farris who's also an associate professor
of political science at Roosevelt
University David I really appreciate
your time today that's been great
chatting thanks for having me on